hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trainsenses.com so i did a full video on
amc yesterday today guys is a full video
only on gme a lot of things happened
this week we had a very very nice
bullish development so let's see exactly
what happened and let's see what can
happen next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys as usual we start daily
timeframe i'm gonna go through the
technicals first i'm gonna show you guys
how to analyze uh this situation using
volatility momentum and
volume and see what levels we might
reach this week or next week
where we might see some rejection
happening uh what levels are good to buy
because i know that this is what you
guys are interested in so as usual i'm
going to just share my view guys let's
see if i am right or not but i'm going
to apply the techniques that i think are
working well in this type of situation
so what is the situation first we're in
a correction guys we're in a correction
or we were in a correction let's see uh
since the november 24th right a b c
so this is some alien to f theory and uh
the question we're having is that right
now we can see yes that rules are taking
back control right
it's pretty obvious i mean you can check
the weekly time frame even if you want
and i showed you guys before that we had
the first bullish week green week
since
almost three months guys
and right now we have this huge green
candle happening after a breakout guys
after a breakout so this is looking
great we can feel [ __ ] back in
control now let's analyze if they are
really back in control so to know that
we need to understand what technically
happened for
bulls to actually take back control and
what happened guys is a breakout and
once again uh i'm building a full course
about this uh method guys which is
trading whenever you have these bullish
signals and i've been doing that for
years guys and i can tell you that it's
full of traps okay the market is full of
traps some traps are really set by big
money investors especially on stocks
like amc and gme and they are really not
easy to avoid like those ones we had
here before and some traps are just you
know natural because the market is just
uh you know you have buyers sellers and
they just trap each other sometimes even
knowing about it so here
is it a bull trap or not to answer that
question we need to check if the
breakout is good quality so once again
i'm going to apply exactly what i'm
showing you guys in this course where
explain how to know if a breakout will
hold or not and if it is supposed to
hold how to enter and how to take
profits on your trades i'm also giving a
lot of risk management strategies that
you guys can apply to be
consistent in your results because as
you know sometimes the market is moving
against you sometimes is moving with you
so you know you just need to have a
strict risk management so that you
survive during hard times and you make
money whenever the environment is better
so for those who are interested just
click on the link in the description of
this video you're gonna subscribe to the
elliott wave course that i did one year
ago guys don't worry i'm gonna have your
email and i'm gonna send you all the
information you need to have to get
access to this new course that is gonna
arrive into a maximum three weeks just
need to finish a couple of things but i
can already tell you guys it's gonna be
amazing and i'm sure you're gonna love
it you're gonna learn a lot a lot of
good information that can be used for
trading so here i'm going to show you a
little bit what it is about okay so we
have a breakout we're going to use
volume volatility and momentum to know
if this breakout is a good quality
breakout so first let's have a look at
the volume
so we can see guys where is the bracket
first
okay the breakout is here
okay
this is a breakout why because we had
the trend line okay
uh a trendline that had
multiple reactions one two but three
four five six all right those small
reactions in the recent past is what is
telling me that uh this was a resistance
area okay
then we break out here let's check the
volume the volume is increasing guys
okay you can see but now is it
increasing a lot or is it increasing a
little bit
here it's increasing a little bit okay
why a little bit because as you can see
it's still lower than a lot of other
volumes we had
in the recent past so
we have the volume increase
but it's not incredible first thing then
do we have
a balance between boos and bears before
breakout because once again i'm not
gonna go too much into details here but
this is very important for a reversal to
be a sustainable reversal you need to
have this balance that is showing that
bears are ready to let it go if you
don't have it
it's probably just gonna you know
they're gonna keep attacking attacking
attacking so first you need to make sure
they're out of the trade and here we
have this consideration it's quite nice
here yes okay between 87 and 115
for like two weeks
we had the the market that just is
posing here and you can see that here
bears and blues are neutralizing each
other uh what i don't like is that it
didn't happen on low volume okay so
basically this was not really a period
of balance this was actually a huge
fight
and a lot of volume has been traded so
the consideration is not perfect until
here
the
five last days before this breakout guys
okay
here we have this you know nice
consideration very close to the trend
line and it happened on low volume on
decreasing volume and we reached some
very low volume it's like you know
everybody was really in a wait and see
mode to see what they do boos and bears
were not training no one was training
everybody was waiting waiting for what
for a signal okay and the signal
happened here
so this is looking great all right so
for now the volume is giving me mixed
signals but the volume dynamics is
giving me good signals the volatility
which is actually this consolidation
that is here is giving me good signal
we can also check the bollinger bands to
know if the volatility has dropped low
enough here the bollinger bands are not
very tight guys so it's showing that
this
you know fight between boots and bears
is still on okay whenever it's dropping
really a lot like here okay you can see
that
whenever the bollinger bands are very
tight it means that you know nobody
cares about what is happening and
everybody is really waiting
so here the consideration is not like i
said perfect we've seen that before and
it's confirmed by bollinger bands that
are not tight enough okay so volume
so so but quite good volatility same
so-so because we have a nice
consideration just before breakout but
the bollinger bands are not very tight
and the last
indicator i wanna check guys is the
momentum so it's the macd and we just
need to check if the momentum is with us
guys okay
uh because if it's not then it's
probably gonna be a fake out and here
the momentum is going higher as you can
see but it's not positive yet the macd
is here i'm not checking the macd signal
i don't use that but i'm checking the
macd and i like the mighty to be
positive it's not positive yet but it's
going to be soon i think so at least the
momentum is going on the upside but we
don't have
here the momentum going higher you see
between a and c the momentum is dropping
so we don't have a bullish divergence so
the momentum is giving good signals but
not perfect so the conclusion is that
this breakout is good but is not perfect
all right so whenever you have a good
breakout that is not perfect you might
expect
a little pullback to happen or you know
maybe some more consolation happening
afterwards and here
uh we are already consolidating you can
see between 130 and 115 this is the new
consideration area we were here guys
now
you know we just went higher so next
level and i think we're going to
consolidate here with maybe some little
dip okay it can happen so be prepared i
think it's going to be a nice
opportunity to buy if we dip
slightly below this 150 level we have
the 20-day moving average at 107
so this is what i think will happen this
week we would consolidate between 115
and 130 with maybe a deep quick deep 210
107 okay the 20-day moving average will
increase soon and once again guys what
i'm showing you here is exactly what i'm
going to show you in my course detailing
every entry method you can make and here
i'm showing you a little bit how this is
uh working but you need to associate you
need to combine fibs with moving
averages with uh areas of consolidation
okay so that's why i'm showing you this
example i think it's very interesting so
in this situation what i would
personally be doing uh i would be a
buyer uh here guys okay just a little
bit below this 115 level okay so that if
there is here a small dip i'm gonna be
able to get in and then what can happen
guys we can expect this breakout
to be followed by a continuation on the
upside and
you know
probably going at least to this level so
i'm sorry
so once again like we've seen guys this
breakout is good quality but not perfect
so there is a chance that this breakout
doesn't hold let's be honest there's
always a chance but i mean when the
bracket is perfect the chances are
smaller here it's not perfect once again
because we didn't to me consolidate long
enough before this breakout but if it
holds and if it's followed by a nice
move afterwards then the usual situation
is that we move
you know higher we can say that a little
bit and then we come to the major
resistance level guys 160. so my view
i'm giving you my view here yes because
once again you know i'm not hiding
sometimes i'm wrong sometimes i'm right
you know most of the time i'm giving you
the levels where you can see there is
some reaction and i'm gonna keep doing
that guys and here my view is that once
again next week we consolidate maybe we
dip a little bit and then we move higher
to the 160 level maybe end of feb
a beginning of march something like that
and this would be the major level to
break like we've tried guys here
unfortunately we didn't manage to do it
you remember we had this two fake outs
guys here
so let's see the next one might be the
right one
so this is what i'm monitoring guys and
i would like the price action to come
here consolidate as long as possible
guys to give energy to the breakouts
that's why a good consideration is very
important because if you don't
consolidate before moving higher you
don't have energy right it's like you
forgot to put oil in your car before
going for a long journey guys so if you
don't have that energy the breakouts
might fade okay so let's see if we
manage to get close to the streamline
could see that and then break out above
160 so a bit like amc guys i think the
scenario might happen in april may
something like that but that from now on
i think
it should be all right for uh gme and i
think things would look better
so let's quickly check the option market
guys what do we have on gme bam bam so
i'm checking the put market get
synthetic short bam
okay so i'm retrieving all the
information
okay so what do we have first
information guys let's check everything
the synthetic shot is three percent and
it can go up to 23 guys it's massive
it's huge let me check what it was
before you see on amc we only go to 15
for now on gme we already go to 23 so it
means there are a lot a lot of options
on the upside which once again would
create a lot of trouble for option
market makers that would need to buy
very decent sizes on the upside
okay
okay so in november it was closer to 30
so it's still lower than november but
it's huge guys 23 of maximum synthetic
short is absolutely massive all right
and
we have this 950 strike 1.2 million
shares right now on the strikes it's
still huge
okay
so the regular shot is still 15 but i'm
using 14th of jan data i really want to
see if some shots have covered or not so
i'm gonna see next week guys when the
new regular shot will be released so the
total shot is 18 right now i take the
synthetic shot i add it to the regular
shot so 18 dtc at three
okay last week the dtc was at
3.15 so we are in line nothing crazy as
you can see jme could go to five six
when it almost squeezed so we are still
far from it guys we need to rebuild you
know everything and i've been saying for
quite some time that we need time i'm
still saying we need time but right now
i'm saying that we reached the low i
really believe that i mean if this
breakout holds so let's see but it it
looks like it will hold but we still
need more time guys to rebuild
everything here okay we are not ready to
squeeze it will take at least i think
two three months but at least from now
we should you know stop dropping and
consolidate and even go a little bit
higher that's what i think
okay so tc at three and yeah so
as you can see those information is
showing that shots are still they have
of course not covered it's still
important the dtc is still high guys
three is high it can go to six but three
is higher already and let's check the um
maximum pen for option
expiry on fab 18s
as you can see guys it's very flat all
right so it doesn't really tells me a
lot let me zoom in here a little bit i
don't see well
okay i don't see very well but it seems
to be around 115 okay
so 120 30 million 32 million
120 it's around 120 okay so the maximum
pain is around 120 so it makes sense
guys it makes sense it seems like within
next week we will finish somewhere
between 115 and 130 so this is in line
with my analysis okay guys so that's it
for me today i hope you enjoyed this
video i hope i managed to explain how i
uh analyzed all the information i have
on the market and if you did enjoy this
video guys please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore see you guys